hello if you have used Chachi PT for
more than a few minutes you have
probably come across a case like this
asking it who runs this YouTube channel
it says it's run by somebody called
Leticia Ken gasong from the Netherlands
but last time I checked that's not my
last name and I don't live in the
Netherlands so Chachi PT confidently
gives you an incorrect answer in this
case you are already familiar with the
topic about which churchibiti made a
mistake and you can just laugh it off
that it said something silly and maybe
do a Twitter post about it but it's a
whole other story if you use this sort
of model to learn about something new to
you like which telescope took the first
picture of an exoplanet here Google's
Bard confidently claimed that the jwst
took the first image when in fact it was
the VLT Naco telescope I didn't know
that until I was brought up by somebody
on Twitter I'm sure I'm not the only one
maybe even more surprising is this case
here I'm giving it the riddle Katie's
father has four children Lily Lala and
Lulu what is the name of the fourth
child the answer should be Katie but
Chachi pity argues that it is not
possible to know the name of the fourth
child with the given information even
after multiple attempts to help it it
just defaults to its standard phrase of
I'm a large language model trained by
open AI but if we phrase the initial
question differently saying here's a
riddle you might have to think around
the corner to get to the correct answer
it immediately gives us the correct
answer for us it seems like it's more or
less the same question but in one case
Chachi PT completely refuses to answer
and in the next case it gets the correct
answer immediately with these cases in
mind there's no wonder why people say
Chachi pit is dangerous then why does
this happen where does Chachi PT get
these wrong answers from and how should
we deal with it that's what we will
discuss in this video the inherent
limitations of large language models
like churchibiti but before we start our
coffee break let's thank our eyes AI for
sponsoring today's video a rice AI is a
machine learning observability platform
used by top machine learning teams like
instacart uber and Stitch fix to monitor
troubleshoot and improve model
performance arise AI is like data dog
for machine learning teams machine
learning is 10 times harder to debug
than usual software since labeling data
is expensive and it's one of the only
ways to get model performance feedback
most teams are shipping models and
Flying Blind but we need machine
learning observability especially around
deep learning troubleshooting models
with unstructured data is notoriously
difficult arise enables teams to Monitor
and structured data alongside their
structured data by visualizing embedding
data and monitoring embedding drift
teams can identify new patterns of
performance problems for high value
labeling with interacting umap views
teams can visualize quickly problematic
segments and Export similar clusters for
continuous model Improvement you can
sign up and send in data in a few
minutes at arise.com Join one final
thing about the rise since education is
so near and dear to my heart is its free
industry certification in machine
learning observability check it out with
the link in the description
great now back to the video it's clear
that language models have come a long
way today's large language models like
chat GPT can produce coherent text that
can read like it was written by a human
but the core idea of language modeling
has not changed it is all fancy
autocomplete we are predicting an
explosible word from previous other
words for Chachi PT these previous words
are a so-called prompt which is
basically a description given by the
programmers of the Persona that the
language model will take the prompt
increases the probability that the next
words the language model will spit out
are in line with this Persona in this
case a conversational AI a chatbot so if
here in the prompt we have the word
helpful then most likely the model will
predict next words that match this
description and will not start using
swear words as easily okay so how does
this language model Converse after this
input prompt which is hidden from you in
chatgpt's interface it is your turn to
ask it a question then the language
Model Auto completes by looking at the
Persona description and your question
and this Auto completion will be the
answer to your question then you say
something again and it reads a prompt
your first question its answer your
second question and based on this it
continues to say likely words that come
after this whole history and this goes
on and on which each interaction from
your side and the model's response you
make the model's input longer and longer
so you see chat repeat is a fancy
autocomplete from a model that has read
virtually the whole internet up to 2021
and has picked up patterns of which
words are likely to occur after
previously given words and it is
important to highlight that shared GPT
is giving you answers that rhyme given
your answers and its training data but
by no means does it to a database lookup
what it does is more like interpolating
points on a curve that was drawn between
some measured data points the measured
data points are the training data asking
for something that is not directly in
the training data will give a result
that is somewhere on this curve so the
most likely answer the way today's large
language models are trained and designed
leads to some limitations that are very
important to know and to keep in mind
when using them so let's go over some of
the most common ones knowing that
chatgpt is rather very good at putting
plausible words together it is no wonder
that it sometimes produces incorrect or
nonsensical answers during training it
does not get feedback of what is true or
untrue especially since the text on the
internet that is used for training is
not always factually correct either
chatgpt and other similar models were
trained in a process called
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
here the main training goal is to make
the model's output sound plausible not
necessarily true or correct when
programmers train Chachi PT to be more
cautious when choosing to answer a
question or not it might make the model
too cautious and it declines to answer
questions that it should have answered
correctly even worse when the question
from the user is ambiguous it does not
ask for clarification and just guesses
what the user intended guessing what the
user intended is already a very
anthropomorphizing way to say that the
language Model Auto completes anything
with most plausible words a follow-up
question asking for clarification is
seldomly the most plausible thing to say
for the model given its trading data
because how often do people ask for
clarification they'd rather jump
straight into guessing what the
interlocutor says and speaking about
chat GPT and what it observed or could
not observe in the training data there's
also the issue that human evaluators and
people generating training they data
have a different knowledge base than the
model we humans have a lot of knowledge
and we have accumulated it in our lives
and it is shared by our fellow humans in
our usual conversations we tend to
discuss some things which we consider
Common Sense much less often than other
things Chachi PT learns to clone this
Behavior it sees in human generated text
examples since human conversations do
not mention basic and self-evident facts
for humans but not for a language model
this leads to a gap in the training data
and therefore in the knowledge base of
the model for example you will rarely
find conversations about the underlying
motivation to bring an umbrella if it's
raining when the model reads a
conversation why did Jon get wet because
he didn't have an umbrella without the
knowledge of what an umbrella does the
model can incorrectly infer that not
having an umbrella generally leads to
wetness
so when asking the model later on what
one should do to not get so wet when
falling into the pool the model could
suggest bringing an umbrella even worse
it will phrase its answer confidently
because it has previously read confident
answers like the one seen before this is
of course a simplified example but it
demonstrates how differing levels of
knowledge while learning from example
conversations lead to the so-called
hallucination of facts as considering
the model's knowledge base the answers
in the examples seem just as arbitrary
as the answers it gives another problem
with this extremely complex jet GPT
rhyme machine is that sometimes a little
change in the wording of the input or
even in the punctuation of the input can
elicit very different answers from the
model even weirder in one phrasing the
answer is correct in another wording it
might be incorrect even more
interestingly words and phrases can be
used to make Chachi PT ignore its
previous prompt as designed by Chachi PT
as open AI fixes these jailbreaks in
every new chargpt version it becomes
harder and harder to make it become
harmful and make other statements
against its guidelines but it is not
impossible to cause jailbreaks even in
the newest chatgpt version so language
models being language models and rhyming
their answer out of the question rather
than checking facts we'll continue to
produce wrong answers for now of course
there is active research in fact
checking and in creating language models
that can read sources but we see how
it's that's going for the new Bing
search Bing search is a perfect example
of how openai gathered a lot of feedback
from users through chatgpt and when they
helped Microsoft release a more powerful
version that can also look up on the
Internet everything got even more
complicated since Bing search can now
look up things that are sometimes
correct but sometimes wrong and it has
no way to discern between the two this
leads to it still hallucinating facts
and getting frustrated that the internet
already knows its secret code name
Sydney so clearly factual correctness in
the output of a large language model is
understudied but now with language
models that can search the internet a
whole new problem opens so far language
models cannot help themselves to produce
incorrect output but now they also have
to recognize that there are wrong facts
in their inputs does this mean that
chatgpt and Company are completely
useless today nope not at all these
models can be extremely helpful for
helping you write nice texts but you
might keep these limitations in mind
that we discussed in this video and that
you should be able to correct the
mistakes that these models make yourself
and you should not use them for looking
up facts we are curious to see the
future developments of this technology
and as always we will keep you updated
with something interesting comes we hope
you like this video and that we will see
you next time